bonsoir alexis alors décidément l eczéma
qui aime jouer les trouble fête dans
dans cette campagne alors qu'on doit le
rappeler il n'est pas encore candidat
c'est dans son intérêt de laisser planer
le doute parce qu'il peut continuer
d'être ce sniper et de dire que tout le
monde est nul sauf lui alors lui n'a
aucun programme mais ce n'est pas grave
il peut continuer de dire que les
républicains sont trop mous que marine
le pen être pas gaucher que lui c'est le
rpr qui les gaullistes alors même qu'ils
nient l'héritage du général de gaulle
lorsqu'il est révisionniste pour dire
que pétain a sauvé des juifs de france
la réalité est triste non le maréchal
pétain a fait en sorte que des juifs
français soit déporté il faut le redire
c'est du révisionnisme et on le laisse
dire en plateau c'est bien tout le
problème d'eric zemmour ça qu'il peut
être dans l'outrance perpétuelle
permanente il court il court le zemmour
et il n'arrête jamais de raconter à peu
près n'importe quoi sans programme
puisqu'il n'est pas candidat
officiellement et de continuer de dire
que les autres ne sont pas à la hauteur
alors un moment il va falloir qu'il se
déclare et qu'il aussi annonce une
équipe et un vrai programme au delà de
sa marotte 1,2 ce qui fait son succès
finalement d'avoir dénoncé une certaine
islamisation de la république de la
france le risque étant là mais qu'est ce
qu'il se passe après cela quand on
demande à eric zemmour qu'est ce que
vous faites les gens qui ne veulent pas
s'assimiler qu'est ce que vous faites
les gens qui ont le prénom mohamed alors
là il ya plus personne n'y a pas de plan
en réalité parce qu'ils les polémistes
et il a bien du mal à être un candidat
donc c'est facile pour lui il a intérêt
à rester comme ça le plus longtemps
possible pour vendre son livre est une
question évidemment qui revient souvent
désormais comment classer eric zemmour
on viens de l'entendre jean françois
copé qui nous dit qu'il est d en tout
cas qu'il tient un discours d d'extrême
droite alors c'est un opni alors hop
nice et objet politique non identifié
c'est ça alors l'obtenir je dirais que
cette fuite ou emmanuel macron qui n'est
ni de droite ni de gauche qui n'est pas
là qui n'est nulle part qui n'a aucune
colonne vertébrale idéologique si ce
n'est à un néolibéralisme vous la
social-démocratie en quelque sorte c'est
merkel français emmanuel macron donc
c'est plutôt lui qui est non identifiés
et le succès zemmour vient de là c'est à
dire que lui il creuse un sillon le même
depuis des dizaines dan et celui de
lutter contre l'islamisation celui aussi
de revenir sur cette idée de faire un
rpr de se dire gaulliste alors qu'il
défend des idées de jean marie open
revenir sur les lois mémorielles revenir
aussi sur les cours de justice
internationale tout ce qu'il dit eric
zemmour il est très facilement classable
à l'extrême droite en réalité avec
évidemment la différence que ce n'est
pas l'extrême droite de jean marie le
pen à l'époque puisque jean marie le pen
lui était avait une partie antisémites
avaient toute cette frange la historique
la zemmour c'est assez différent mais ça
reste quand même assez classique dans ce
discours pareil sur le déclin de la
france c'est quelque chose qu'on a
toujours entendu dans les cercles
d'extrême droite ça ne change pas non
plus donc il n'ya pas de question à se
poser aussi dit si on a une la réponse
est facile oui eric zemmour pour moi et
d'extrême droite et alexis paulin
évidemment les républicains on en parle
également parce qu'ils ont passé une
étape quand même important pour eux ce
week-end ils ont choisi de désigner
finalement leur candidat sous la forme
d'un congrès pas d'une d'une primaire
c'est une trahison pour les électeurs de
droite qu'est ce que ce choix signifie
ce choix est difficilement
compréhensible en réalité parce que on a
là un party les républicains qui était
un grand parti qui vient justement de
cette frange gaulliste puis qui a fait
l'ump puis les républicains et qui se
recroqueville sur lui-même on a
l'impression que les républicains en
tant que parti aujourd'hui a peur de
redevenir un parti populaire donc c'est
un parti effectivement et là on peut
donner raison à eric zemmour de notables
de gens qui décident entre eux
finalement derrière des portes closes de
qui sera le candidat et la chose en plus
la plus extraordinaire c'est que vous
allez avoir au sein de ce congrès des
gens comme xavier bertrand et valérie
pécresse qui ne sont plus encarté qui
vont venir quand même chercher
l'adoubement de ce parti donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose
d'incompréhensible pour un militant et
c'est aussi la question qui se pose
finalement là encore on peut voir la
patte des mails macron qui après avoir
déconstruit la gauche puisque c'est à la
mode de déconstruire en ce moment est en
train de déconstruire la droite du moins
la droite le fait tout seul avec ceux
qui ne veulent pas le dire mais qui sont
déjà en marche comme que christian
estrosi et d'autres et ceux qui pensent
déjà à la prêt à faire une droite dure
différentes
avec eric zemmour ou non mais qui voit
qu'ils regardent déjà ailleurs donc
c'est un parti en train de se fissurer
de se scinder en deux sans le dire avec
ce congrès qui arrive en descendant
c'est incompréhensible en terme de
timing pour finalement choisir un
candidat peut-être un peu trop tard
alors xavier bertrand lui le voulait ce
congrès est ce qu ils aient la garantie
selon vous on comprend votre propos que
pas forcément mais est ce qu'il est la
garantie de l'unité de l'ue
rassemblement des candidats à l'issue du
voc au moins dépendre à lui efi dément
pas ce qu'il peut refuser ce sommet
comme il le voulait c'est peut-être une
victoire pour lui c'est aussi une façon
de calmer l'hypothèse bertrand et de
rassurer les candidats qui voulait une
primaire donc c'est un peu un entre deux
difficile ce qui va se passer là dans
les semaines qui viennent c'est que
chacun va faire campagne à sa façon les
uns contre les autres pour essayer
d'aller chercher les militants des
républicains mais pas allés chercher les
français c'est ça qui risque d'être
difficile à la fin c'est comment être un
candidat rassembleur plus large que
celui qui aura fait de la politique
interne ça rappelle un peu le parti
socialiste avant sa chute on est
vraiment là dedans dans les derniers
jours je pense les derniers mois des
républicains à suivre donc merci alexis
poulain d'avoir été avec nous